[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend auf welche
politische Weltbühne man auch immer
schaut klopfen sich Männer kräftig auf
die Schultern versichern sich dass sie
beieinander stehen komme was wolle und
dass sie am Ende auch siegen werden
beiden mit silensky Putin mit den
Mullahs etwas undurchsichtig bleibt die
Rolle Chinas Problem an der Sache zwar
reden alle zumeist aber nur übereinander
statt miteinander was ist aber gibt sind
Wortgefechte auf Distanz die nicht
annähernd zufrieden führen ultra der
sowohl in den USA als auch in China
Korrespondent war fragt sich wo uns das
alles eigentlich hinführen wird dieses
Duell der Weltmächte das Putin heute vor
seinen Anhängern in einem Moskauer
Stadion fortführte
der neue Kalte Krieg ist ein Duell mit
Auftritten mit Bildern als
Durchhalteparolen als Kampfansage
es ist eine drohende Schlacht der
Systeme Diktatur gegen
Freiheit
nicht nur musikalisch gestern ein
anderer Auftritt
US-Präsident beiden als Schutzpatron der
Zukunft das sind die Glaubenssätze an
die Bevölkerung
wer hält länger durch eine entscheidende
Kriegsfrage
das ist eine Schlacht für unsere
Bevölkerung um unser historischen
Grenzen zu verteidigen unsere Kämpfer
werden vom gleichen mutigen Geist
geführt den wir auch bei den Soldaten
finden die hier mit uns stehen
Putin als Taktgeber der nur noch sich
selbst zuhört
das Volk als echo-kammer
es erinnert an dunkle Zeiten der
Geschichte ein Hauch von totaler
Kriegsbegeisterung in Moskau die
schaudern lässt wir sind stolz auf
unsere Kämpfer zu ihren ehrenrufen wir
ein dreifaches hurra
[Applaus]
Vorfahrten des unumstrittenen Anführers
der freien Welt Amerika und beiden gehen
in dieser Rolle auf er trifft in
Warschau osteuropäische Verbündete die
scharen sich um den US-Präsidenten denn
sie spüren schon den kalten
kriegerischen Atem Russlands europa
braucht den Schutz der Amerikaner um
seine Freiheit zu sichern
ihre Länder markieren die Frontlinie
unseres Verteidigungsbündnisses sie
wissen was auf dem Spiel steht nicht nur
für die Ukraine sondern für die gesamte
Freiheit in Europa und der ganzen Welt
der dritte im Bund der weltmächtigen der
chinesische Präsident Chi äußert sich
nicht zur Ukraine Krise erwartet ab
während sich Russland und Amerika
duellieren
Chi schickt seinen Chef Diplomaten vangy
heute nach Moskau im Gepäck einen
Friedensvertrag der die staatliche
Souveränität garantieren soll aber
trotzdem Russlands Verhalten nicht
kritisiert die Diktatoren Achse China
Russland zeigt keine Risse unsere
Beziehung entwickelte sich wie geplant
sagt Putin sie bewegen sich nur vorwärts
äh Rutsche
vorwärts immer rückwärts nimmer das
Motto das bis nach Deutschland halt die
Sehnsucht nach Frieden in den
Demokratien beobachtet Peking und Moskau
genau der Friedensvertrag soll sie
verführen eine zynische Strategie
ist völlig klar dass die chinesische
Seite hofft dass im Westen sich auch
diese öffentliche Meinung spaltet und
die politischen Entscheider auch nicht
mehr sozusagen hinter dieser
Unterstützung der Ukraine stehen gegen
Russland stehen auf Dauer das ist ganz
klar das Interesse und insofern wird
immer wieder Initiativen geben die im
Grunde diese Einigkeit und diese
gemeinsame Linie mit den USA versuchen
zu aufzuspalten es geht bei diesem
Konflikt ums große durchhalten putin ist
angeschlagen sie wartet ab und
beobachtet die USA beiden ist der
Hoffnungsträger aber sein Land ist tief
gespalten das ist die größte Gefahr für
die Freiheit
die entscheidende Hoffnung in Peking ist
dass die USA sozusagen sich selbst
zerlegen dann ist die Zeit Chinas
gekommen dann wird sich Chinas globale
Führungsposition zeigen und die wird
unangreifbar werden das ist die
Kalkulation im Peking
Präsident beiden verlässt Warschau mit
dem Treueschwur dass Amerika der Garant
der Freiheit bleibt die Ukraine und
Europa hoffen darauf
ultra ich sagte es bereits war lange als
Studioleiter in den USA und China jetzt
berichtet er für uns aus Brüssel Ulf
einen schönen guten Abend ich hatte
Eingang schon gesagt alle reden nur
nicht wirklich miteinander warum
eigentlich nicht würde denn ein
Gesprächsangebot als einknicken gewertet
werden
ich glaube einfach dass die Weltmächte
noch nicht die Phase erreicht haben wo
wirklich ernsthaft über Verhandlungen
nachgedacht wird und wo Verhandlung auf
den Tisch gelegt werden die dann
bewertet werden ob sie stark oder
schwach sind sondern leider man ist man
noch in der Phase wo man sehr tief in
diesem Krieg verstrickt ist und
wahrscheinlich beide Seiten auch noch
glauben dass sie Gewinner erzielen
können es gilt ja für die Russen
eigentlich eine bittere Erkenntnis sie
hatten gedacht sie würden ein schnellen
Triumph erzielen und nun sehen sie dass
der Westen doch sehr sehr geschlossen
ist und eigentlich dieser Krieg der
Russen die NATO wiederbelebt hat und das
Bündnis so stark ist wie noch nie das
macht vor allem die Chinesen sehr sehr
misstrauisch und Sie glauben dass
Demokratien vielleicht doch nicht so
lange durchhalten deshalb dieses
Testangebot des Friedensinitiative die
sich starten wollen eigentlich ist es
eine unfriedensinitiative um zu gucken
wie groß die Solidarität im Westen mit
der Ukraine ist ein Jahr nach dem Krieg
ist das Fazit ganz einfach der Krieg
geht weiter so traurig das ist bitte
Realität du hast gerade dieses
Friedensangebot angesprochen china will
das am Freitag auf den Tisch legen holen
wir jetzt an dieser Stelle Johannes
Hanau hinzu der für uns in New York die
Sondersitzung der Vereinten Nationen
beobachtet Johannes im vergangenen Jahr
gab es ja eine Resolution gegen Russland
143 der insgesamt 193 Mitgliedstaaten
hatten sich dagegen die
völkerrechtswidrige Annexionen in der
Ukraine gestellt ist denn jetzt schon
absehbar was dieses Jahr passiert
ja die Ukraine hat gerade eben eine
Resolution eingebracht in der die
Weltgemeinschaft aufgefordert wird alles
zu unternehmen alle diplomatischen
Bemühungen zu unternehmen um
schnellstmöglich einen Frieden auf Basis
der Prinzipien der Karte der Vereinten
Nationen herzustellen also territoriale
Souveränität und territoriale Integrität
Weißrussland Russland Verbündeter hat
einen zusatzamt man eingebracht die
sagen das geht nur wenn wir auch keine
Waffen mehr liefern das steht jetzt dann
möglicherweise auch noch zur Abstimmung
bislang war so dass die Ukraine
Resolution mit sehr sehr großer Mehrheit
hier angenommen worden sind in der
Generalversammlung aber hinter
vorgehaltener Hand ist man sich da jetzt
nicht mehr so ganz sicher denn viele
Länder vor allen Dingen das globalen
Südens haben die Nase voll die sagen das
ist nicht unser Krieg und ihr benutzt
uns hier nur ihr müsst mir für uns tun
ihr benutzt die Vereinten Nationen für
eure Sachen aber nicht für uns und es
kann durchaus sein dass jetzt viele
sagen okay so billig sind wir nicht zu
haben und die Abstimmungsverhalten
verändern die große Frage die allerdings
jetzt noch im Raum steht ob China sein
Abstimmungsverhalten verändert bislang
hat China sich ja immer der Stimme
enthalten was man hier als großen Erfolg
gewertet hat dass China sich nicht an
die Seite Russlands gestellt hat sollte
das jetzt nach den jüngsten
Entwicklungen anders werden und China
mit Russland stimmen dann wäre das hier
ein Paukenschlag der noch sehr sehr
lange nachhallen wird
dann sind wir gespannt wie China sich
verhält vielen Dank an euch beide also
vielen Dank Ulf nach Brüssel und vielen
Dank Johannes nach New York
ja nach fast einem Jahr können wir
festhalten auch bei der einer der am
besten dokumentierten Kriege der Welt
ist er zeigt seine hässliche Fratze in
all seinen Facetten mal ganz abgesehen
bisher jedenfalls von atomaren
biologischen und chemischen Waffen
weisenhäuser Schulen
Bildungseinrichtungen wurden bombardiert
Frauen vergewaltigt Kinder entführt eine
Gruppe weisenkinder konnte sich zusammen
mit der Heimleiterin aus den Fängen der
Russen befreien Armen Körper und Arndt
zeigen uns diese unglaubliche Geschichte
mit Happy End selten genug in diesen
Zeiten
so sieht es aus wenn die Besatzer auf
kinderjagd gehen Carson im Sommer 2022
noch ist die Region unter russischer
Kontrolle die Kinder hier sind weisen
sie sollen nach Russland verschleppt
werden auch Natalia war mit ihren 15
weisen Kindern in diesem Haus drei
Monate lang
zuvor hatten die Russen sie bereits aus
einem anderen heim nach herson gebracht
doch eines Morgens kommt auch hier ein
Bus der Besatzer die sagten wenn du
nicht in 10 Minuten gepackt hast gehen
die Kinder ohne dich wir nehmen sie dir
weg ich hatte keine Wahl
das war beängstigend wir wussten nicht
wohin sie uns bringen dann sagten sie
sie würden uns in die Ferien bringen
die Reise führt zum Fluss Nepper von
dort geht es auf die Halbinsel Krim
Natalia wird klar sie bringen Sie nach
Russland bei Nacht mit dem Zug über die
Brücke von Kerz die krimbrücke
vollläufiges ziel dieses Haus in der
russischen Stadt anapa am Schwarzen Meer
[Musik]
in dem Gebäude waren etwa 500 Menschen
auf vier Stockwerken es waren sehr viele
Kinder da sie stammten alle aus der
oblastrealson sie kamen alle aus der
Ukraine
ich denke sie bringen sie dorthin damit
sie sich daran gewöhnen damit sie
bleiben
die größte Gefahr ist dass die Kinder
sich womöglich anpassen aber sie hängen
an mir im Herzen die Ukraine es sind ja
ukrainische Kinder
doch sie sollen Russen werden so zeigen
es diese russischen Propaganda Bilder
von bis zu 14.000 verschleppten Kindern
spricht die ukrainische Regierung sie
werden ihrer Identität beraubt und
russifiziert die Staatsbürgerschaft auf
dem Silbertablett zuständig dafür Putins
Ombudsfrau für Kinderrechte
ich stehe hier und begreife dass diese
Kinder sich komplett verändert haben es
ist fantastisch
Natalia und ihren Kindern gelingt die
Flucht mit von ihr selbst gefälschten
Dokumenten heute sind sie in Georgien
ja ich habe die Dokumente gefälscht aber
ich habe es für die Kinder getan und es
hat funktioniert was aber wenn nicht sie
hätten in Russland bleiben müssen
[Musik]
die Verschleppung Russifizierung und
Umerziehung von Menschen Tradition aus
Sowjet Zeiten eine Praxis die Putins
Russland heute noch anwendet auch an
wehrlosen Kindern
die verschwundenen Kinder von Herr Sonne
auf der Spur eines Kriegsverbrechens die
ganze Geschichte von Arndt Genzel sehen
sie gleich im Anschluss an unsere
Sendung also in ZDF Zoom gestern haben
wir hier ja ausführlich über das
Todesurteil eines deutsch-iranas
berichtet heute zieht Deutschland Hannah
erste Konsequenzen damit beginnst du ja
als Reaktionen auf das Todesurteil eines
iranischen Gerichts gegen den Deutsch
Iraner schamat hat die Bundesregierung
zwei iranische Diplomaten ausgewiesen
das erklärte bundesaußenministerin
bärbock außerdem habe sie den
Geschäftsträger der iranischen Botschaft
einbestellen lassen im Deutsch Iraner
wird von einem Revolutionsgericht in
Teheran unter anderem vorgeworfen an
einem Terroranschlag beteiligt gewesen
zu sein
die türkische Regierung will Betroffenen
der Erdbebenkatastrophe finanziell
helfen das geht aus einem Dekret hervor
dass der türkische Präsident Erdogan
heute erlassen hat konkret soll den
Menschen durch Kurzarbeitergeld lohnen
Unterstützung und ein Kündigungsverbot
geholfen werden in den Provinzen in
denen der Ausnahmezustand verhängt wurde
ist eine monatliche Auszahlung von rund
200 € pro Person geplant durch das
schwere Beben vor mehr als zwei Wochen
starben in der Türkei und Syrien mehr
als 48.000 Menschen Millionen wurden
obdachlos
ja und um die Betroffenen im
Katastrophengebiet zu unterstützen hat
das
Bundesverteidigungsministerium der
Türkei Angeboten mobile
sanitätseinrichtungen in die Region zu
verlegen diese ermöglichen es unter
anderem Operationen durchzuführen
bislang hat Deutschland rund 40.000
Betten 500 Zelte mehr als 300
Generatoren sowie 200 Beatmungsgeräte in
die Türkei geliefert das erklärte ein
Sprecher des Innenministeriums
die Zahl der Asylbewerber in der
Europäischen Union sowie der Schweiz und
Norwegen ist im vergangenen Jahr stark
gestiegen und damit so hoch wie seit
2016 nicht mehr insgesamt wurden
966.000 Anträge gestellt das ist ein
Plus von 50% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr so
die EU Asylbehörde die meisten
Antragsteller kamen aus Syrien
Afghanistan und der Türkei nicht
eingerechnet sind die rund 4 Millionen
Ukrainer die in der EU aufgenommen
wurden
die Nachrichten aus Israel und den
Palästinensergebieten sind wirklich sehr
beunruhigend zum einen sorgt Israels
neue extreme Rechte Regierung für Unmut
weil sie mehrere einst
völkerrechtswidrig errichtete Siedlungen
im bestjordanland nachträglich jetzt
legalisieren will und zum anderen kommt
es in letzter Zeit immer wieder zu
Anschlägen auch heute starben wieder
Menschen dieses Mal bei einem Einsatz
des israelischen Militärs in NA bloß die
Stadt gilt als Hochburg militanter
Palästinenser und die drohen jetzt mit
Vergeltung Michael Beverungen
Rauch über nahtlos und wie so oft in
diesem Konflikt ist es schwer Anfang und
Ende der Gewalt zu verorten sicher ist
das ein gepanzerter Militärkonvoi der
Israelis am Morgen in NA bloß eindringt
er wird mit Steinen angegriffen die
Soldaten Antworten mit trennen Gas
die Armee beteuert sie sei auf der Suche
nach Terrorverdächtigen der Miliz Lions
den gewesen ein Terrorangriff habe
unmittelbar bevor gestanden sonst wäre
man das Risiko eine Razzia bei Tag gar
nicht eingegangen ein Anwohner
eine große Zahl von Soldaten stürmte das
Areal und belagerte das ganze Gebiet wir
bleiben im Haus wir wussten nicht was
vor sich ging wir hörten nur die Stimmen
der Soldaten sie hatten Karten dabei und
wir hörten Explosionen für eine lange
Zeit nur Explosionen und Gewehr Feuer
die Situation eskaliert die Verdächtigen
werden in einem Haus gestellt es kommt
zu einem schweren Feuergefecht die
Israelis feiern Raketen ab und geraten
selbst unter immer stärkeres Gewehrfeuer
herbeigealter meditationäre ein Offizier
der golani Brigade erklärt anonym seine
Soldaten hätten die gesuchten
neutralisiert und andere die geschossen
hätten wir versuchten das Gebiet
abzuschotten während dutzende bewaffnete
Männer auf unsere Einsatzkräfte feuerten
neutralisieren das bedeutet in der
israelischen Militärsprache töten und
dieses Mal ist der Blut soll besonders
hoch mindestens 11 Tote und über 100
Verletzte darunter wie so oft Zivilisten
auf einem Video ist zu sehen wie
flüchtende niedergeschossen werden ob
sie Unbeteiligte sind oder nicht ist
bisher ungeklärt die israelische Armee
will die Aufnahme nicht kommentieren die
Palästinenser sind empört
die israelischen Soldaten nehmen keine
Rücksicht auf Bewohner oder Kinder
einige junge Männer wurden getötet
darunter ein 14 Jahre alter Junge
seit einem Jahr laufen tödliche Gefechte
wie dieses nach dem immer selben Muster
ab ein Grund die palästinensische
Regierung hat die Kontrolle über die
jungen Kämpfer in nahtlos oder Jenny
verloren doch von dort geht immer wieder
Terror aus also nimmt Israel die
Verfolgung der Täter selbst in die Hand
als Antwort folgt neuer Terror viele
Israelis sehen nun bedrückt dem nächsten
Anschlag entgegen gerade das könnte
wieder mal eskalieren Terroranschläge
Raketen aus Gaza ich weiß es nicht
der Zyklus der Gewalt im Nahen Osten so
berechenbar und doch so unaufhaltsam
damit zurück nach Deutschland jede
Partei cdu/csu SPD bis hin zur FDP den
Grünen oder den linken sie alle haben
eine Stiftung die ihn nahe steht diese
werden jedes Jahr mit über 600 Millionen
Euro vom Bund finanziert der Kuchen ist
also verteilt und neue Mitesser sind
nicht wirklich gern gesehen das ist
natürlich kein Argument für das
Bundesverfassungsgericht der Grund warum
das Gericht heute der Klage der AFD in
Teilen recht gab deren Stiftung nämlich
bisher von der Zuwendung ausgeschlossen
war ist ein anderer das Urteil könnte
die stiftungsfinanzierung jedenfalls neu
regeln Christoph Schneider
vor der Urteilsverkündung vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht Proteste von
Aktivisten mit Gesichtsmasken des AFD
Ehrenvorsitzenden Alexander gauland und
von Erika Steinbach der Vorsitzende der
AFD nahm die siderius Erasmus Stiftung
kurz die is Steinbach nimmt auch
persönlich an der Urteilsverkündung Teil
es geht um viel Geld denn alle im
Bundestag vertretenden Parteien haben
eigene Partei nach Stiftungen die
bekommen staatliche Finanzmittel in
insgesamt dreistelliger Millionenhöhe
nur die die es erhält kein Geld dagegen
zieht die AFD vor das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das eine
Benachteiligung feststellt
bei der staatlichen Förderung der Partei
nahen Stiftungen handelt es sich um eine
für die Ausgestaltung unserer
demokratischen Ordnung wesentliche Frage
die der Regelung durch ein eigenes
Gesetz Bedarf das heißt für die
Verteilung von Stiftungsgeldern braucht
es eine klare gesetzliche Grundlage die
bislang fehlt das bislang allein der
Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestags seine
jährliche Festlegung trifft ist
unzureichend die AFD begrüßt das Urteil
die vielen hundert Millionen 660
Millionen Euro im Jahr können jetzt
nicht mehr in irgendwelchen
stiftungsgesprächen im Hinterzimmer
vergeben werden sondern müssen ganz
klaren gesetzlichen Regelungen folgen
das ist ein sehr kleiner Sieg für die
AFD und die die Sirius erasmus-stiftung
weil damit nicht gesagt ist das
automatisch Ansprüche bestehen weder für
die Vergangenheit noch für die Zukunft
sondern das einzige was Karlsruhe heute
gesagt hat ist es muss ein Gesetz her
das soll nun auch so schnell wie möglich
kommen verspricht die FDP
jetzt ist der Ball ins Spielfeld des
Parlaments das heißt wir werden uns
jetzt nicht nur darum bemühen sondern
wir werden zeitnah einen Vorschlag
erarbeiten wie wir das gesetzlich
umsetzen eine künftige Voraussetzung
könnte sein dass seine Stiftung mit
beiden Beinen auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes stehen muss denn das
Gericht hat im Urteil auch klar gemacht
der Schutz der freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung kann den
Ausschluss verfassungsfeindlicher
Stiftungen rechtfertigen die Idee der
Stiftung ist ja die dass Sie wenn Sie
wollen demokratische Bildungsarbeit
betreiben ja nicht nur politische
sondern eben auch demokratische das soll
der gemeinsame Nenner aller Stiftungen
sein und genau da gibt es bei der des
bei der erasmus-stiftung eben durchaus
Fragezeichen ob die Desiderius
erasmus-stiftung tatsächlich
verfassungsfeindlich ist hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht heute nicht
bewertet sondern den Gesetzgeber in die
Pflicht genommen der muss die
stiftungsfinanzierung nun rechtssicher
ausgestalten
Tarifrunden gehen uns irgendwie alle was
an denn wenn diese scheitern dann gibt
es meist Streik und der soll jetzt
möglichst abgewendet werden damit
beginnen die weiteren Nachrichten mit
Hanna ja es lohnt also ein Blick auf die
Tarifverhandlungen im öffentlichen
Dienst heute wurde die zweite
Verhandlungsrunde eingeläutet flankiert
von weiteren Streiks die den Druck auf
bunt und Kommunen erhöhen sollen die
Forderungen die sind klar allerdings
Frank Bethmann ein Angebot haben die
Arbeitgeber bisher noch nicht vorgelegt
nein auch in dieser zweiten
Verhandlungsrunde die morgen weitergehen
sollen haben die Arbeitgeber bisher noch
kein Angebot vorgelegt
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer
versuchte vor Beginn der Verhandlungen
eine Brücke zu bauen sie werden sich
dafür einsetzen dass die Arbeitgeber in
dieser zweiten Verhandlungsrunde einen
Angebot vorlegen aber sie müsste auf die
Kommunen Rücksicht nehmen welche die
meisten Angestellten in ihren rein
beschäftigen die wiederum die Kommunen
klagen man lege doch noch sehr weit
auseinander
Verdi und der deutsche Beamtenbund
fordern für die rund 2,5 Millionen
Angestellten des Bundes und der Kommunen
10,5% monatlich jedoch mindestens 500
Euro mehr Gehalt was wird denn erwartet
sollten sich die beiden Parteien nicht
einigen dann das kündigte wer die Chef
Frank Wernicke im Vorfeld bereits an
würden die nächsten Streik zum und die
hätten dann eine andere Dimension den
Arbeitgebern dürfte klar sein rote
Wernicke dass der öffentliche Dienst
dann ganz vielen Stellen Arbeitskampf
fähig sei die aber während sich diese
Streik Androgen würden ja suggerieren
dass sich die andere Seite nicht bewegen
würde das Stimme aber nicht auch die
Arbeitgeber sein der Ansicht dass gute
Arbeit anständig entlohnt werden muss
nur was anständig am Ende in Euro
bedeutet darüber ist man sich bislang
nicht einig vielen Dank für diese
Einordnung
die Teuerungsrate für das vergangene
Jahr ist vom Statistischen Bundesamt neu
berechnet worden und liegt nun deutlich
niedriger so wurde die Inflationsrate
2022 von bislang 7,9 Prozent auf 6,9%
korrigiert grund dafür ist eine Änderung
der Gewichtung und Zusammenstellung des
Warenkorbs mit dem die Rate berechnet
wird dieser orientiert sich jetzt an den
Konsumgewohnheiten aus dem Basisjahr
2020 statt 2015
Tarifverträge dürfen unterschiedlich
hohe Zuschläge für regelmäßige und
unregelmäßige Nachtarbeit vorsehen das
hat das Bundesarbeitsgericht in einem
Grundsatzurteil entschieden und so die
Klage einer Mitarbeiterin eines Getränke
Herstellers abgewiesen konkret ging es
um Zuschläge von 20 Prozent für
regelmäßige sowie 50% für unregelmäßige
Nachtarbeit die Ungleichbehandlung seit
zulässig wenn hierfür ein sachlicher
grundvorliege so das Gericht
das Urteil hat nach Einschätzung von
Experten eine Signalwirkung für etwa
6000 anhängige Klagen
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Mittwoch
die lauten 4 6 9 27 44 46 und die
Superzahl 8 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
Tradition ist was feines nur manchmal
vergisst man woher sie eigentlich stammt
der politische Aschermittwoch
beispielsweise der geht auf eine
Versammlung des bayerischen Bauernbundes
im Jahr wissen sie es 1919 in Vilshofen
zurück lange war diese spezielle Art der
Auseinandersetzung eine niederbayerische
aber was sehr gut funktioniert wird dann
gerne auch mal kopiert und so hat
Politik gepaart mit Polemik auch bei
anderen Parteien Anklang gefunden Stefan
leifert über den Aschermittwoch der nach
zwei Jahren Zwangspause anders begann
als gedacht
das große Comeback beginnt mit einer
kleinen Panne der Einzug des CSU-Chefs
ist schon in vollen Gange da merkt die
Kapelle sie spielt den falschen Marsch
Schrecksekunde Abbruch dann erklingt
doch noch der bayerische defiliermarsch
es soll das Comeback der Institution
Aschermittwoch werden und vor allem das
Comeback des volkstribuns Markus Söder
[Musik]
wir sind die stärksten wer sind die
besten wer ist in den Wasser
eineinhalb Stunden lang arbeitet sich
Söder an der Berliner Ampel ab eine Rede
zwischen Kalauer und Krieg mit Inbrunst
und Schauspielkunst changieren zwischen
laut und ganz laut das Leitmotiv ist
schlicht
die neue Bundesregierung die Ampel ist
die schlechteste Bundesregierung die
Deutschland je hatte liebe Freunde
Söder testet Pointen und Parolen für
seinen schicksalswahlkampf im Herbst auf
eins hat er sich aber schon festgelegt
ob Gegner sind die Grünen und alles was
sich danach anfühlt wir essen wieder
Schweinsbraten statt
in Venedig grüne dann könnte das Zeug
selber fressen wir machen das nicht
niemals
Ukraine Krieg und Weltpolitik sind weit
weg in Passau in der Grauzone zwischen
Fakten und Gefühlen führt Söder einen
Kulturkampf auf zwischen
Bodenständigkeit und wirknis zwischen
einem wir und einem die
gender Pflicht in bayerischen Schulen
und Hochschulen lehnen wir ab ist mit
der CSU nicht zu machen
das ist doch nimmer normal das ist doch
völlig überdreht wir lassen uns von den
Grünen nicht Kultur und Sprache um mal
sehen nein nein nein
100 Kilometer weiter auch Blasmusik nur
anders in Landshut versuchen die Grünen
einen Aschermittwoch und auch hier
schafft es Markus Söder mit seiner
Identitätspolitik prominent auf die
Bühne lieber Söder ich kann Ihnen eines
versprechen es ist mir komplett egal wie
sie reden was mir nicht egal ist ist das
hier in den letzten Jahren der Ausbau
der Windkraft für schlafen wurde und so
das Potenzial von Bayern nicht genutzt
wurde was mir nicht egal ist ist das so
Markus Söder den Wohlstand Bayerns und
damit auch den Wohlstand Deutschlands
gefährdet der Aschermittwoch lässt den
Sound erahnen in dem im Herbst um die
Macht in Bayern gekämpft wird es ist
ausgerechnet die CSU die die rein der
ampelparteien zumindest einen Tag lang
ganz fest schließt die lenken mit ihren
Kultur Kämpfen von ihrer miserablen
Politik ab und ich sage euch wir lassen
den das nicht durchgehen wir reden über
den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren über
sozialen Wohnraum wir reden über gute
Löhne und wir machen nicht deren Politik
mit mag die CSU sich am politischen
Mitbewerber abarbeiten wir als Freie
Demokraten wir arbeiten uns vor allen
Dingen an den Problemen der Menschen in
diesem Land ab das ist eben der
Unterschied zwischen uns und denen
und so gelingt es der CSU und ihren
Vorsitzenden einen Aschermittwoch lang
Referenzpunkt aller anderen Parteien zu
sein sowas hat sie tatsächlich lange
nicht gesehen
[Applaus]
und wir haben uns entschieden zwischen
ihr und wir wir sind definitiv fürs Bier
absolut und ich habe hier auf meinem
Papier noch einen Hinweis auf unser
heute journal Update gegen 0 Uhr mit
Nazan göktemir das war von uns machen
sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter nach der schweren
Dürre in Teilen Europas im letzten Jahr
setzt sich die Dürre weiter fort denn im
Herbst und im Winter viel zu wenig Regen
z.B am Fluss Po ist das gut zu erkennen
das Flussbett sticht hier hervor in weiß
es ist viel zu wenig Regen teilweise
sind Rekord niedrigstände erreicht
worden ja und diese Trockenheit die wird
nur leicht quasi abgemildert mit etwas
Regen in der Poebene das reicht
natürlich nicht um die Defizite von
einem Jahr auszugleichen und auch zu
wenig Regen und Schnee gab es Richtung
Schweiz hier kommt nun auch etwas dazu
ja und auch in Deutschland wird es etwas
regnen und geben und das wird sich
weiter nach Osten durchsetzen und dann
bekommen wir tatsächlich
am Wochenende ein Winteranbruch light
aus dem Norden in der Nacht gibt es von
Westen her Regen ansonsten im Osten
trocken ja nach Südosten gibt es Nebel
die Temperaturen sinken dabei auf zwei
Grad Richtung Berlin-Brandenburg und 8
Grad am Niederrhein und morgen kommt der
Regen etwa bis zur Mitte voran zum Abend
hin dann in den Osten und dort gibt es
sogar noch etwas Sonnenschein vorher bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 6 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein und 15 Grad im
Südwesten noch mal sehr mit dann gibt es
am Freitag Schnee von Norden etwa bis
zur Mitte in den Mittelgebirgen 12 Grad
maximal und danach wird es kühler und
mit ergiebigen Schneefall an den Alpen
bei 1 bis 8 Grad damit ein schöner Abend